a group of Rebel Fighters moves into
position on a hillside in eastern
Myanmar they start to assemble a
fixed-wing drone one of the most potent
weapons in their fight against myanmar's
military government
when we're fighting on the front line
our drone team is the first to enter the
area it has many positive effects on the
ground attack
we can fly discreetly into enemy
territory and over their bases
a small commercial drone is launched
this is the Scout soon they're hovering
over a Myanmar Army position the
soldiers below oblivious to the threat
the attack drone is loaded with
Munitions and launched into the sky
using the remote they maneuver into
position
the Scout drone films the target
puffs of smoke as the bombs hit their
mark
the unit was put together to challenge
the superiority of myanmar's military in
the air
they found their inspiration in a
different conflict far away
when we were assigned the Drone Mission
we were incredibly inspired by the
Ukrainian forces during their War we
were inspired by their use of drones to
attack tanks
hidden deep in Jungle camps they're
using surprisingly high-tech solutions
to adapt designs for hobbyists into
building attack drones
with the resources scarce they're
limited to basic building materials wood
and polystyrene
but on 3D printed frames
to produce this Liberator Mark II we use
3D printing and molding to create a
basic frame then our design is printed
out and we use resin to mold the entire
body
myanmar's military has also been
bolstering its power in the sky attack
helicopters and fighter jets on display
at this year's military Day Parade
with ground troops facing stubborn
resistance they're unchallenged in the
air
that power has been used to its full
effect since the military coup
this Village in segang was attacked by
military helicopters in April a
legitimate Target they said more than
150 people were killed and dozens of
children amongst the Dead
the rebels are all too aware their
homemade drones will have little impact
on the gunships and fighter jets but
they say it's the best they can do
and now they also have the ability to
strike from the skies Tony Chang Al
Jazeera